[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans point
de vue ravi de vous retrouver puisque
nous ne sommes pas confiné et d'ailleurs
on va en parler de ce confinement
puisque nos deux invités ont en commun
d'être assez réservé c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire vis-à-vis des
nouvelles mesures sanitaires du
gouvernement bonsoir ferghana ziari vous
êtes analyste en politiques publiques
que vous collaborez notamment ali rêve
qui est un think tank libéral vous êtes
aussi délégué général de l'académie des
sciences humaines et nous accueillons
aussi guillaume bernard bonsoir soit
guillaume vous êtes maître de
conférences à l'institut catholique
d'études supérieures et auteur de la
guerre à droite aura bien lieu
le mouvement dextrogyre aux éditions
desclée de brouwer
leur confinement nous allons en parler
mais pas tout de suite je voudrais si
vous le voulez bien que nous passions
d'abord quelques minutes pour nous
interroger sur la bonne réponse à
l'islamisme et notamment mais pas
seulement à son expression la plus
violente et la plus barbare qui est le
terrorisme et ont fait évidemment
allusion aux événements de nice est ce
que la bonne réponse c'est pour faire
court la république la laïcité les
valeurs universelles et lumière ou est
ce que c'est la civilisation
l'enracinement certains diraient
l'identité certains comme françois
xavier bellamy écoutez c'était la
semaine dernière sur sud radio
on ne pourra combattre l'islamisme
efficacement que si on s'est retrouvé la
force de cette identité de cette culture
de cette civilisation de cette manière
de vivre qu'il faut défendre enfin
maintenant une bonne fois pour toutes
qu'il faut s'assumer
on est qu'il faut pouvoir franchir voilà
et c'est aussi la thèse de notre ami
eric zemmour il la développe dans le
figaro magazine de ce week-end
j'en profite si vous ne l'avez pas
encore acheté pour vous dire que notre
numéro est consacré cette semaine à
michel onfray est donc dans ce numéro
il n'y a pas que michel onfray même s'il
fait le dossier de couverture
eric zemmour explique que les
terroristes ne vise pas la république
mais la france une france à la foi
chrétienne et irrévérencieuse la france
des croisés et de l'assiette au beurre
là c'est au beurre 6 août est parce que
c'est parce que c'était un petit peu
anciens maintenant c'était un journal de
caricatures c'est un peu le lancer de
charlie hebdo l'assiette au beurre ou
pas guillaume bernard guth et historien
je suis pas sûr qu'il y ait une volonté
dans l'assiette au beurre je dirais de
de déstructurer le corps social qui a
quand même chez charlie hebdo qui fait
que je suis pas de ceux qui apprécient
forcément le travail de ses journalistes
alors ce serait un autre débat mais ça
n'est pas celui de ce soir et sinon sur
cette question ferghana diaries est ce
que la réponse d'un libéral c'est de
dire ben oui le la meilleure façon de
riposter à
un communautarisme c'est la liberté mais
la liberté universelle où la liberté
ancrée dans l'identité terroristes
la france est en partie vrai il était
invité la civilisation finances a
annoncé mme ensemble pour liquider ce
qu'ils font aujourd'hui les principes
constitutifs de l'association
occidentale la liberté le pluralisme en
effet l'égalité hommes-femmes la
séparation du spirituel et du temporel
une notion qui est inconnu de la
civilisation islamique donc cette
accusation et moi j'ai peur qu en
opposant finalement à une identité un
peu franchouillard pour le dire vite à
l'islamisme j'ai peur qu'on ne fait qu
poser un particularisme à un
universalisme l'islam c'est une religion
qui se veut universelle je pense que
monde et construire à cette religion si
on lui oppose un autre projet universel
parce que se situer sur le terrain des
traditions de l'identité pourquoi pas un
mais c'est aussi je crois donné des
arguments intellectuelle aux islamistes
qui sont légitimes à dire chez eux
vous voyez l'islam est une religion
kabyle qui a 100 ans qu'on est légitime
a fauté les hérétiques chez nous parce
que c'est quand on a toujours fait or
moi je pense que cette religion
il faut la défaire la déconstruire à la
fois en europe occidentale mais aussi à
l'extérieur de la civilisation
occidentale parce qu'elle fait des
ravages
aussi bien au maghreb en asie proche
orient donc c'est un enjeu de
civilisation mais en utilisation l'effet
universel et pas seulement franco
français je pense que c'est là dessus
qu'il faut attaquer et des contre cette
religion en tant que telle dieu vous
avez des éléments à peut-être opposés
afin d'y arriver je vous donne d'abord
le point de vue de nos internautes qui
n'est pas forcément votre d'ailleurs
mais je ne veux pas anticiper sur votre
réponse la laïcité était la meilleure
réponse à l'islamisme radical
et bien c'est oui c'est un oui écrasant
mais c'est un oui à 56,5 pour cent
réponse donc de tous ceux qui nous
suivent et on les en remercie sur
twitter vous pouvez aussi réagir sur
twitter achetable point de vue est
également sur lefigaro.fr et sur youtube
sur youtube où nous entendons diana qui
nous dit étant donné que tous les pays
européens souffrent les attaques
jihadistes alors ça c'est un peu une
autre question pourquoi pensez-vous que
la france est la plus touchée
donc on a un peu traître a peut-être ce
sujet après mais voici un point de vue
darcos dit sur lefigaro.fr
la laïcité n'est qu'un aspect du
problème c'est la france et la
civilisation que l'on a attaqué
guillaume bernard oui moi je suis
effectivement plutôt de cet avis je
partage le point de vue de bellamy et
zemmour ça n'étonnera pas grand monde
pour ceux qui me connaissent bon jeu on
n'est pas socialiste ici comme on a fait
ça mais on les assigne pas à résidence
autre expression à la mode
pas encore en tout cas
intellectuellement mais ça ne le
pourrais peut-être que malheureusement
arriver un de ces jours non il me semble
que c'est effectivement alors la france
la civilisation occidentale qui est
agressé par l'islamisme et pas
simplement des valeurs ou des principes
de ce abstrait le
les attaques de l'islamisme contre
l'occident il ne date pas des
caricatures de charlie hebdo c'est bien
antérieur il ne donne pas non plus je
tiens à le dire ici quand même ça ne
date pas non plus de 1948 c'est bien
antérieur et est par conséquent il ne
faut pas croire que c'est les 38 heures
doit la création de la création de
l'état juif tout simplement derrière ne
faut pas croire parce qu'il y aune
l'occident reste soutenu la création de
l'état juif en 1948 et bien il y aurait
tout d'un coup une hostilité de l'islam
envers l'occident le style i t il la
volonté de conquête de l'islam date des
débuts de l'islam et et cette volonté de
conquête
eh bien elle prend des formes
différentes des formes soft des formes
plus dur en fonction des circonstances
et des rapports de force et il n'y a pas
de différence
malheureusement
il peut y avoir des individus qui ont
des conduites différentes naturellement
et je ne parle pas ici de la fois des
individus je parle bien de la conduite
politique et sociale mais il peut y
avoir il n'ya pas vers est
malheureusement de différence de de
nature entre l'islam et l'islamisme
il y a une volonté de conquête général
et de une volonté impérialiste qui
cherche dans le fond a remplacé une
civilisation par une autre alors je ne
crois pas contrairement à fergane là
c'est un point de désaccord profond que
l'on puisse opposer à l'islam
il vient simplement des idées juridique
ou des principes d'organisation de
société il faut véritablement une une
une philosophie ou une religion qui est
généré un véritable ancrage qui est une
transcendance et qui soit capable de lui
répondre je ne crois pas que la
république laïque soit en capacité de
répondre à l'islam et qu'en revanche le
christianisme lui est en capacité de le
faire
jeux jeux la république laïque dans le
fond elle a créé les conditions par
anticatholicisme par anticléricalisme
elle a affaibli l'identité de la france
et de l'occident est aujourd'hui l'islam
profitent des circonstances profitent du
vide qui a été créée et la laïcité qui a
été la cause ou l'une des causes de
notre affaiblissement et bien serait
aujourd'hui présenté comme étant un
remède
je n'y crois absolument pas ce qui
pourrait appeler traître la réponse à la
question de diana pourquoi la france
est-elle la plus touchée
peut-être parce que justement c'est elle
qui a théorisé la laïcité de façon
spécifique mais c'est pas que la laïcité
qui est agressée huberdeau si ça n'était
que la laïcité il y aurait eu des
attentats sur l hebdo ya n'aurait pas
dans des églises des des prêtres le père
hamel qui a été assassiné hier encore à
nice des personnes dans une église qui
ont été qui ont été tués c'est bien
l'ensemble je dirais du groupe social
qu'ils veulent conquérir et qu'ils
veulent soumettre
oui sur la laïcité je suis pas d'accord
pour dire que c'est ce principe cela qui
nous a affaiblis en revanche ce qui est
vrai c'est que ça ne suffira pas c'est à
dire que une fois opposé l'argument de
la laïcité à une religion qui par
essence ni la distinction entre le
spirituel et le temporel
c'est pour moi un peu ce faire la
promotion de la gastronomie française
avait gagné un mur il ya un système de
croyances qui sont ils et des siennes ne
sera pas compatible
parce que on n'arrive pas à concevoir
que la laddh cette distinction entre le
spirituel et le temporel et une
projection qui est typiquement
occidentale qui ne va pas de soi c'est à
dire que nous fixions entre ce qui
relève du fn vous avez raison la laïcité
dans le challenge vous savez tout à fait
raison la laïcité n'est pas une
invention du 19e siècle
elle a été théorisée par des penseurs
qui sont bien antérieurs à son appel
aujourd'hui l'ère moderne
donc c'est en effet là la culture
chrétienne est là dans ses prémices une
plus forte tolérance pourrait-on dire
effectivement cette distinction entre le
spirituel et le temporel
alors que alors ça se ressent même dans
notre manière de death cris de décrire
l'islam et l'islamisme
nous on fait la distinction islam
islamisme et en arabe la langue
liturgique du coran cette distinction
n'existe pas l'islam ça désigne à la
fois la religion le système politique
l'idéologie politique les règles de vie
qui vont avec
donc moi je pense que ce qu'il faut
c'est davantage déconstruire cette
idéologie cette religion en tant que tel
puisque lui opposer la laïcité montré
que cette religion ne correspond pas à
ce qu'on pourrait appeler les exigences
de vérité de justice de paix qui fonde
une société véritablement civilisé
bernard même si vous pouvez le regretter
le mouvement de déchristianisation de la
france est profond il est probablement
durable
ça veut dire que vous êtes pessimiste
pour l'avenir puisque face à cela on
voit qu'il ya un communautarisme
musulman qui même s'il n'est pas
généralisée parmi nos compatriotes de
cette confession est quand même assez
assez fort et assez présent oui
malheureusement effectivement il ya un
vide spirituel et intellectuel peut être
au sens plus large dans notre société
qui fait qu évidemment elle a des
difficultés réelles à résister à quelque
chose qui est viril qui est fort qui
s'affirme qui s'affiche et qui n'a pas
l'intention de céder donc les jours qui
viennent et les années qui viennent
risque effectivement d'être une une
situation extrêmement difficile pour
nous est ce que pour autant il va
falloir basculer dans une stratégie de
l'iso là pour se protéger contre
effectivement cette cet impérialisme
je ne le souhaite pas mais il ne faut
peut-être pas évacuer totalement évacuée
totalement cette idée nos hommes
politiques qui sont en partie
responsables de la situation ont eux
mêmes reconnu et bien que on pourrait ne
pas simplement vivre côte à côte mais
face à face donc dans ces conditions là
on ne peut malheureusement être que
pessimiste j'ajouterai une toute petite
chose
bien entendu le christianisme est à
l'origine de la possibilité de concevoir
la laïcité par la distinction des
domaines par le fait qu'il faut rendre à
césar et qu'il faut rendre à dieu mais
pour autant dans le christianisme la
distinction des domaines suppose qu'il y
ait la présence dans l'ordre public et
de ce qui doit être rendu à dieu et de
ce qui doit être rendu à césar donc et
du spirituel et du politique mais la
laïcité elle en revanche prétend exclure
le spirituel de l'ordre public et
exercer un monopole du politique sur
l'espace public ça c'est une grande
différence c'est à dire que oui la
laïcité n'aurait pas pu être conçue en
dehors d'un monde où le christianisme
avait effectivement établi la
distinction des domaines mais pour
autant la laïcité c'est quelque chose de
parfaitement différents à mon sens
je n'irai pas jusqu'à dire que c'est le
vide spirituel qui a permis
effectivement à l'idéologie islamiste
s'infiltrent la société je pense que il
ya aussi le fait que nous sommes
aujourd'hui régenté par une doctrine
relativise passe moderne qui depuis des
années des décennies estime finalement
qu'il faut abandonner toute possibilité
de hiérarchiser les cultures et c'est
dans ce relativisme là que les
islamistes se sont engouffrés puisque
pendant que nous nous désarme ion
pendant que nous nous abandonnions notre
universalisme notre la conviction en
effet que la civilisation occidentale en
tant qu' en tant que l'ordre social
fondé sur la philosophie des libertés
l'égalité autre bien eux les islamistes
n'ont pas abandonné le relativisme dire
que eux vêtements ont gardé leur
universalisme avec eux donc nous avons
opposé toutes ces années un relative
isme à un universalisme c'est pour ça
que moi j'insiste sur le fait qu'il
faille opposé un universalisme un autre
universalisme alors c'est ce que la
culture de savoir lequel elle se bat le
christianisme se serait l'humanisme
athée ou à ce sera autre chose ça je ne
sais rien je sais pas je sais pas
compétent pour prononcer là dessus mais
en tout cas ce que je veux bien dire
c'est que on ne pourra pas on a vu les
réactions dans le monde musulman après
les propos d' emmanuel macron qui se
contentait de défendre la libre
expression on a été choqué de voir que
le monde musulman
au lieu de répondre à un attentat qui a
été commis au nom de sa religion et bien
a surenchéri en proposant
d'universaliser la répression du
blasphème en manifestant encore plus
contre les gens que moi je pense que
combattre l'islamisme à l'échelle locale
c'est aussi le combattre à l'échelle
internationale et donc c'est aussi
s'appuyer sur les intellectuels que les
dissidents que produit cette
civilisation musulmane qui existe qui
vivent cachés parce que la peau stasi en
effet ce n'est pas récompensé si je puis
dire dans ces sociétés là et même le
contraire voilà c'est un euphémisme mais
en tout cas c'est un combat universel
donc attention à ne pas se renfermer
dans une perspective franco-française
qui je crois serait paradoxalement le
jeu
d'une idéologie qui elle ne connaît pas
de frontières un dernier mot là dessus
gaubert d'art sur ce sujet en tout cas
pour eux pour aujourd'hui
quand zemmour dit c'est pas la
république qui est visé mais la france
ça veut dire que est ce que le
patriotisme indépendamment de des
convictions religieuses des uns et des
autres peut-être une réponse oui ou en
tout cas la défense de l'identité c'est
à dire le fait de dire que la france ça
n'est quand même pas un no man's land
c'est pas quelque chose qui est
simplement le résultat d'un contrat
social où il y aurait une addition
d'identité parcellaire qui ferait le
tout mais que la france est le résultat
d'une histoire est que cette histoire a
fait que la france a une identité propre
une identité ontologique dont le
fondement est on le sait bien le fait de
la gaule romaine a été réunifiée parler
franc au nom et pour le compte du
catholicisme il n'y aurait pas eu deux
royaumes capétiens s'il n'y avait pas eu
de royaume des francs et ce royaume des
francs c'est la réunification de la
gaule romaine par les mérovingiens au
nom et pour le compte du catholicisme
contre en particulier les aryens les
dissidents les dissidents du
christianisme qui suivait le prêtre
arius donc dans ces conditions la
défendre
c'est bien sûr la france qui est attaqué
mais ce n'est pas que la france pense
que zemmour ne réduit pas son analyse au
cas français même si c'est sans doute
celui qu'ils intéressent le plus
et moi aussi je le dois bien le dire je
dois bien le reconnaître mais c'est bien
mais c'est mais c'est mais celles
identifiées mais c'est l'identité des
pays qui ne sont pas soumis à l'islam
qui est bien agressé
agressé avec énergie c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire lorsque c'est du
terrorisme et agressé aussi par toutes
les volontés je dirais de de conquérir
de l'espace public
culturellement parlant merci beaucoup je
laisse le dernier mot si vous le voulez
bien à nos internautes à grains de ville
sur twitter qui souhaite que les
musulmans prennent part à la lutte
contre les dérives fanatiques en
s'organisant en faisant le ménage dit il
même où dit elle même je ne sais pas si
c'est un homme ou une femme au sein de
leur propre religion
et puis une remarque de jar jar binks
sur lefigaro.fr
la laïcité c'est l'état qui ne veut pas
se mêler des questions religieuses alors
une autre fois nous définirons ce que la
vérité parce que c'est un débat à tout
seul mais je voudrais qu'on importe si
vous le voulez bien le deuxième thème de
notre
émission leur confinement il est
officiel depuis hier minuit même si pas
quelle tolérance encore pour ce week end
alors on a entendu messieurs certains
points qui vous opposait mais là bas il
ya peut-être un point qui vous rapproche
c'est que vous n'êtes pas très chaud
pour ce pour ce confinement guillaume
bernard non je dois dire que si je
devais résumer ma position en deux mots
je dirais que leur confinement c'est
liberticide et c'est mortifère
liberticide pour les différentes
personnes et les différents corps
sociaux de notre société et puis un
mortifère pour le tissu économique et
social mais je crois qu'il faut
s'interroger et sur les mais comment
dire la justification du confinement
puis ensuite sur ses modalités déjà sur
la justification
je suis je fais partie de ceux qui
considèrent que la parole publique est
aujourd'hui décrédibilisé
parce que on a eu droit depuis mars
dernier à des injonctions
contradictoires sur tout un ensemble de
sujets et en particulier évidemment sur
celui du masque et puis il ya
aujourd'hui l'utilisation d'un argument
d'autorité les statistiques qui commence
à devenir un tout petit peu je dirais
douteux et pesant il semblerait quand
même que l'on puisse douter de cette
statistique en tout cas de la manière
dont elles sont présentées par ce que
est ce qu'il n'ya pas de confusion entre
les cas positifs et les malades vraiment
contagieux et sa très franchement
d'après est-ce que je peux écouter des
médecins on peut se poser vraiment la
question
et puis il ya deuxième une deuxième
confusion me semble-t-il c'est tous ceux
qui sont toutes les personnes qui
malheureusement sont décédées en étant
porteuse du que vides mais elles ne sont
pas nécessairement morte du cog vide lui
même et c'est là où effectivement les
arts de l'argument d'autorité des
statistiques me paraît douteux
ah voilà le premier élément déjà sur la
justification ni effet que je suis
extrêmement dubitatif sur l'efficacité
et la juger et hilal
la légitimité de se re confinement je
passe tout de suite la parole afin ghana
diaries mais pas avant de vous avoir
montré ce sondage qui illustre votre
position minoritaire messieurs puisque
70 % des français sont favorables au
nouveau confinement jusqu'au 1er
décembre au moins annoncé par le
président de la république et notre
quelqu'un de twitter qui n'est pas un
sondage puisque ce sont les internautes
qui suivent l'émission en direct qui
s'expriment mais la tendance est quand
même là même êtes vous opposé au
confinement
c'est non à 70 2% archos geek toujours
sur lefigaro.fr nous explique que le
confinement c'est ce qui reste quand
tout a échoué fer canadien harry ça veut
dire qu'on ne pouvait pas faire
autrement c'est la vie de l'immense
majorité des français c'est là où je
suis en désaccord alors pas pour les
mêmes raisons que guillaume mois sur la
question des statistiques je ne me
prononcerai pas parce que je ne suis pas
compétent un effet pour préjuger de la
qualité aujourd'hui arguments sur la
situation du virus
en revanche là où je trouve que le
confinement est une décision
complètement irrationnel pour 4 la
manière dont ça a été fait c'est que ça
a été fait en l'absence de calcul coûts
bénéfices et c'est ça moi qui me frappe
c'est à dire que on nous dit que on va
encore une fois privilégier la vie sur
l'économie c'est un mensonge
la vraie question qu'on aurait dû poser
depuis le début c'est combien de gens
sommes nous prêts à affamer pour ne pas
avoir à engorger les hôpitaux combien de
gens sommes nous prêts à tuer de la
pauvreté pour ne pas faire en sorte que
des gens meurent faute de soins parce
que ceux qui aujourd'hui oppose la vie à
l'économie sont des gens qui ignorent
peut-être parce qu'ils sont dans une
situation qui est confortable
financièrement mais qui ignore que la
pauvreté elles tuent aussi mais ça vous
voyez tout le monde s'en fiche moi je me
suis fait insulter sur les réseaux
sociaux parce qu'à un moment j'ai
suggéré
quand j'ai vu les chiffres de l'onu
quand j'ai vu qu'ils avaient 490
millions de gens qui à l'échelle du
monde retombe dans une misère noire
quand je vois que le secours populaire
par delà la plus grande précarité depuis
la seconde guerre mondiale quand j'ai vu
ces chiffres là je me suis demandé si un
moment l'engorgement des hôpitaux
n'allait pas être un moindre mal comparé
aux souffrances que nous sommes en train
figée je me suis fait insulter pour une
raison très simple c'est que la pauvreté
elle tue à petit feu
elle tue de manière diffuse mais il y en
a pas du voir sociales considérables
comme l associé à 100 milliards d'euros
du plan de relance alors c'est beaucoup
pour les entreprises à l'est aussi pour
les gens ça ne suffit pas et d'autant
plus quand une fois on oublie
aujourd'hui de la pauvreté c'est le
principal facteur de risque reste le
principal facteur de risque de mortalité
dans le monde
j'ai les chiffres sous les yeux en 2017
le les données du global burden of
disease nous apprennent que 365 millions
d'années de vie en bonne santé ont été
perdues en raison par exemple des
maladies cardiovasculaires l' oms nous
dit que deux tiers de ces décès sont
dans les pays en voie d'émergence est en
voie de développement ça veut dire que
encore une fois nous échangeons des vies
contre d'autres vies est ce à dire que
nous nous épargnons plus de vie que nous
n'en détruisent ont en réalité nous n'en
savons rien personne n'est capable de
répondre oui à cette question tout le
monde admet agir ici au nom du principe
de précaution
sauf que c'est un tricot sionisme
étriqué parce que il ne se préoccupe que
des risques de la liberté et ils
ignorent ce de sa suspension
guillaume bernard peut-être que sans
doute même que par vos convictions
personnelles vous êtes attachés à la vie
à la protection de la vie et donc vous
n'êtes pas sensible à cet argument quand
même que même si on peut peut-être
détruire des vies ultérieurement comme
vient nous dire ferghana on en sauve à
court terme en enfermant les gens chez
eux
non mais ça c'est que je vois bien que
vous utilisez pour relancer le débat
pour le nourrir je dirai ce qui est
utilisé comme principal argument mais un
argument qui cherche à intimider les
personnes en disant si vous êtes contre
leur confinement c'est qu'effectivement
vous ne prenez pas en considération en
particulier la vie des personnes des
personnes âgées mais on pouvait
parfaitement envisager me semble-t-il
et d'aucuns en ont parlé 1
un confinement cible et sélective sur
les personnes les plus fragiles et puis
et là je rejoins fergane sur ce point
même si c'est une manière un peu
différente de présenter la chose c'est
le critère de la délimitation entre les
activités autorisées et les activités
interdites qui est quand même
extrêmement brumeux fumeux
pourquoi est ce que on ferme les bars
mais pas les transports en commun locaux
vides serait donc beaucoup plus
dangereux dans les barques dans les
queues dans les transports mais certains
ont les bars sont peut-être un tout
petit peu moins indispensable que les
transports en commun mais mais si pour
qui c'est à dire que le rôle et le
barman qui subvient à ses besoins qui se
nourrit en vendant de l'alcool il exerça
métier tout aussi essentiel que celui
qui vend de la nourriture pour payer son
loyer donc encore face à 6tu fausse
dichotomie à mon avis cette séparation
entre les activités essentielles
accessoires pardon jeunes alors mais je
suis parfaitement d'accord l'occurrence
sur ce point et puis il ya une vision
parfaitement matérialiste aussi de la
vie pour le foulage que vous me meut
lanciers sur cette question de la
défense de la vie je défend évidemment
la vie innocente mais c'est un autre
sujet mais en l'occurrence c'est une
vision matérialiste les activités
sportives vont donc être autorisée en
tout cas même de manière limitée mais
elles vont être autorisés en revanche la
liberté de culte est évidemment
extrêmement mise à mal or il me semble
quand même que la masse est besoin que
le corps ne serait méconnaître
et puis je constate d'ailleurs dans
l'analyse que certaines de nos
politiques font de la question de de la
célébration en particulier de la messe
c'est que ils ne font preuve il illustre
le fait qu'ils sont totalement ignorants
sur ces questions ne pas comprendre que
évidemment la messe à une spécifité la
messe catholique a une spécificité par
rapport aux autres cultes c'est qu'il ya
la présence réelle et qu'il y à la
communion et que par conséquent ce n'est
pas simplement le fait de faire une
prière n'est pas de faire mon la
parenthèse là dessus en tout cas les
critères qui permettent de délimiter ce
qui est autorisé de ce qui n'est pas
autorisé me paraissent absolument
arbitraire et
et donc du coup évidemment contestable
il ya eu des manifestations alors assez
limité mais quand même c'était hier à
paris hier soir plast la république
on en a signalé aussi en italie est ce
que vous pensez
sagan a dit harry que le l'opinion peut
se retourner alors qu aujourd'hui elle
est très majoritairement par peur de la
pandémie favorables aux mesures de
confinement ce qui est certain c'est que
le consensus social a été brisée il
n'existe plus le sénat lui-même a voté
je crois guère contre les mesures
sanitaires proposé par par le
gouvernement alors aujourd'hui l'opinion
publique reste majoritairement faire du
confinement pour les raisons que j'ai
déjà exposé c'est à dire que quand une
fois médiatiquement parlant les membres
du cos vide on va dire se sortent
vainqueurs des membres de la pauvreté
parce que jamais le figaro jamais le
monde jamais le parisien ne fera sa vue
une seule madame michu qui a perdu
quatre années d'espérance de vie parce
que cette année elle a pu faire son
check-up parce qu'elle n'est pas des
moyens mais c'est invisible donc on peut
pas montrer à quel point en effet
aujourd'hui le confinement tu maintenant
en effet il n'est pas certain que ce je
pense qu'il aura pas trois dames
confinement ça c'est certain c'est à
dire que si à une troisième vague à mon
avis étant donné que la tolérance et à
juste titre de l'opinion vis-à-vis de
ses mesures sanitaires et autoritaire a
été a été complètement réduite à mon
avis les politiciens un moment vont
devoir faire un arbitrage sinistre il
est douloureux mais il sera d'autant
plus douloureux qui n'aura jamais été
annoncées depuis le début c'est à dire
que moi je suis frappé de voir que les
médecins depuis le début cette pandémie
ne parle pas du confinement avec la voix
qui tremble avec les larmes aux yeux
comme si encore une fois il n'y avait
aucune incidence humanitaire emmanuel
macron lui-même dans son discours à
perpétuer l'invisibilisation des
victimes de ces mesures puisque il a
prétendu qu'il ne faisait que sauver des
vies et rien que ça or on sait que c'est
faux encore une fois alors bruno va dans
votre sens je vais vous donner la parole
bien sûr guillaume dans un instant bruno
sur youtube vous rejoint alors il dit
même que l'appauvrissement ça peut
conduire à des émeutes et des morts
zulte et pourrait être supérieure à ce
que l'on a dit politiquement sauver
c'est vrai même si au niveau mondial
les centaines de milliers de morts du
lac aux vies ne font que c'est de la
marge avant que des morts dans des
émeutes puisse arriver à un niveau
équivalent juste pour venir ce que vous
avez été là pour pallier demeure
hypothétique de la pauvreté c'est pas
hypothétique rien que si on raisonne en
termes de perte de chance par exemple si
on part du principe qu'une enquête soit
plus elles sont statistiques alors que
les morts de la coved on peut donner des
noms plus visible ouais mais elles sont
plus visibles mais est-ce à dire
qu'elles sont moins nombreuses que
celles de la pauvreté rien que si vous
raisonnez sur la base de la perte de
chance quid des gens dont on a prolongé
la souffrance et la condition misérable
alors même que ces gens auraient pu par
exemple sortir de la pauvreté ce qu'on
n'avait pas pris ces mesures
autoritaires
j'essaye un dernier argument qui est en
berne à les médecins nous disent leur
confinement est indispensable pour
pouvoir soigner les gens qu'on ne
pourrait pas accueillir si les hôpitaux
sont engorgés par des malades de la
copie de vous vous entendez cet argument
quand même des gens par exemple ils
peuvent pas suivre leur traitement à
l'hôpital parce qu'il ya plus de place
pour eux oui mais d'abord vous savez
bien que tous les médecins ne tiennent
pas ce discours là un certain nombre
c'est vrai que d'autre part vous parler
uniquement des places dans les hôpitaux
publics et qu' il ya quand même tout un
système de cliniques privées qui
semble-t-il sont laissés totalement tu
dirais de côté dans cette affaire alors
qu'elles pourraient alors qu'elle
pourrait intervenir
et puis moi je suis tout de même frappé
par une chose c'est que sans le dire il
ya toute une idéologie derrière ce ces
choix-là ya l'idéologie a pour le coup
feria ne me suivra peut-être pas sûr sur
ce point mais il ya toute l'idéologie du
contrat social parce que l'idéologie
qu'est ce que c'est avancer l'idée de
dire que l'on est prêt à abandonner tout
ou partie de ces libertés pour avoir la
sécurité
ça c'est pour avoir la conservation
c'est plus un ventre asocial hobbesien
que lo kèr ou de celle qui a quand même
l'abandon d'une partie des libertés
bon il ya 10 20 avril et du contrat d'un
milliard du contrat social d'accord
c'est la conservation en échange de vos
libertés
or je suis au regret de dire d'abord
cette théorie est parfaitement
discutable et que deuxièmement il y a
aucune activité humaine qui ne soient
pas susceptibles de développer à risque
on est en train de d'essayer de nous
imposer une idéologie qui a substitué le
principe de précaution à la vertu de
prudence la vertu de prudence c'est on
est confronté à une situation est
effectivement on fait un choix en
fonction de ce que l'on veut obtenir la
prudence c'est parce que la précaution
pardon c'est sous prétexte qu'il y aura
un risque comme s'il n'y avait pas un
risque dans n'importe quelle activité
humaine eh bien il faut s'abstenir il
faut interdire et il faut détruire les
libertés eh bien ça je ne peux pas
idéologique pour le partager merci
beaucoup c'était point de vue l'émission
site ops et locke quand on parle du rpt
confinement je trouve que l'ambition
était là ce soir merci beaucoup à lui et
c'était grâce à vous et très bon
week-end à tous confinés ou non
[Musique]